et écrire
[Musique]
chanson te rappelles
ton nom
on célèbre aujourd'hui la journée
nationale des peuples autochtones au
canada et stéphane vous avez discuté
avec l'auteure compositrice interprète
élisapie qui va participer au spectacle
la fête nationale du québec le 23 juin
la très talentueuse et les api qui a
grandi à saluer 8 le village le plus au
nord du nunavik et qui pourra célébrer
la culture inuite puisqu'elle va
participer au spectacle de la fête
nationale qui va être présenté dans
quelques jours et va participer au
discours patriotique en compagnie de
fred pellerin christine beaulieu et
david goudreault alors je me demandais
de quoi il s'agit at elle envie de
parler qu'est-ce qu'elle a préparé un
mot dit que ce serait pas un discours
les organisateurs lui ont plutôt demandé
de préparer en compte
ayant pour thème l'unité je trouve c'est
une belle occasion en tant que femmes
autochtones en tant que inouk en tant
que êtres humains de donner ma version
sur cette unité là alors je suis honorée
pour ce petit moment là parce qu'on ne
voit pas beaucoup en
on est encore très très mal représentée
sur présenter leur jeu trop fun
ouais j'ai des maux h des choses à dire
par rapport à ses frontières elle
souhaite que la journée nationale des
peuples autochtones devienne un jour
férié
oui parce que c'est une journée qui
célèbre la diversité culturelle le
patrimoine des premières nations des
inuits des métis mais a dit si on en
faisait un jour férié ça marquerait le
coup ça nous permettrait de mieux se
connaître de se comprendre dit les
autochtones nous ne sommes pas un peuple
nous sommes nombreux et nous avons
différentes langues ce serait vraiment
génial que ça devient une journée fériée
pour que les gens puissent vraiment le
feuilleté aux autres aussi faire un peu
de how i n'est que si c'est qu'ils sont
conscients plus par rapport les peuples
autochtones juste au québec y a dix
nations deux premières nations et les
inuits et aussi qu'on puisse nous donner
plus de place dans les radios à la télé
et qui a un quota parce que c'est comme
ça qu'on puisse assurer notre langue
et pour ce qui est de la fête nationale
du québec à un spectacle très différents
une expérience très différente cette
année pour les animateurs ariane moffatt
pierre lapointe qui était l'année
dernière sur les plaines d'abraham
devant une foule en délire là ils vont
se retrouver demain à l'amphithéâtre de
trois rivières pour une captation sans
public
mais avec une quarantaine d'artistes une
soixantaine de techniciens diffusion le
23 juin à 20h sur les quatre grands
réseaux de télévision
on va regarder ça vient souligner la
fête nationale de cette façon cette
année merci beaucoup stéphane merci